Así es pues es una sequía histórica la
que se está viviendo especialmente en el
suroeste del país en el departamento de
los pirineos orientales donde todas las
cuencas y fuentes hidrográficas están en
sus niveles más bajo más bajo se ven
incluso fotos de algunos pequeños ríos
que están completamente secos donde
solamente se ven piedras flores han
nacido allí Así que a partir de hoy pues
entran estas restricciones Nadie puede
regar los césped no se pueden llenar las
piscinas no se pueden utilizar spas como
por ejemplo jacuzzis que sea esto
también además tanto en digamos en los
espacios públicos como espacios privados
no hay riesgo tampoco de ningún tipo de
de canchas de fútbol por ejemplo ni
tampoco de campos de golf todo esto Pues
con unas restricciones muy importantes
las autoridades que además dijeron que
van a estar muy vigilantes de lo que
cada persona haga en sus casas va a
haber controles bien importantes también
en las casas de los particulares y
además de esto Pues también
restricciones en la Irrigación agrícola
esto preocupa muchísimo a los
agricultores que dicen que pues ya ven
perdidas importantes de sus cultivos el
gobierno que por su parte dice que habrá
también pues eh indemnizaciones para las
pérdidas de los agricultores y en medio
de todo esto Pues también va creciendo
la preocupación por parte de los
bomberos porque con la sequía Pues
también la vegetación está cada vez más
seca Así que bien puede pues esto llevar
a importantes incendios más durante el
verano como los que se vivieron
justamente el año pasado sobre esa misma
época